welcome to Hannity tonight many
Americans they are desperately looking
for ways to rebuild their lives they
want to get back to their jobs they want
to reopen businesses and of course in a
safe responsible way they want to
protect others others have been working
remember we can't forget this non-stop
around the clock they have been keeping
this country going there's been no
shutdown of American farmers or those
Packers or are great truckers or the
manufacturers of medical equipment or
those that have been stocking grocery
stores here at the epicenter in New York
Long Island they will never be reopening
why because they never shut down they
were literally all-american heroes they
were a lifeline for the American people
in an hour of real need they stepped up
they're inspiring stories are incredible
they've been feeding us they've been
sending our medicines logistically
helping all of our hospitals and brave
medical staffs with all the safety
equipment that they desperately need it
in time they got them there's one
example over 40 Braska American
employees there in Pennsylvania they
volunteered the last 28 days they
volunteered to live and stay at their
worksite working day and working all
night every day at factory and what were
they doing desperately needed supplies
for and 95 masks for medical workers
credible story thank you for all you do
and while the vast majority of Americans
are tirelessly working hard to get this
country and their lives back on track
sadly predictable people Democrats their
allies their state-run television medium
mob gleefully looking for ways to
politically bludgeon President Trump
same repulsive people as usual we won't
spend a lot of time on them right now
but some other left publicly now are
actually stating a desire to use a
national emergency in a pandemic as an
opportunity for them to reshape America
into a far-left green New Deal socialist
utopia now recently they ever confused
Joe Biden remember that he was running
for president held the fundraiser
during that fundraiser high dollar
donors quote he said because of this
Kovach crisis I think people are
realizing my lord look at what is
possible look at the institutional
changes that we could make and he said
he was excited by the opportunity so
what is the kind of institutional
changes the ever forgetful Joe is
excited about his former colleague in
the Senate member ed markey he just
tweeted 22 million Americans are out of
work we need to rescue our economy and
create millions of new Union jobs we
need a green new deal we're in the
middle of an emergency trying to save
lives here guys no more planes
no more combustion engine no more cows
no more oil and gas windmills regulation
socialism and a destruction of the
American free market economy and a sense
deleted tweet congresswoman Acacio
Cortez was celebrating the crash oil
prices rioting you absolutely love to
see it this alone with record low
interest rates means it's the right time
for a worker led mass investment in
green infrastructure to save our planet
congresswoman are you that ignorant you
don't understand
millions and millions of high-paying
career jobs of Americans will disappear
in a second
and by the way oil and gas are the
lifeblood of the world's economy in
spite of your fantasies about 10 years
12 years from now to that end she's now
calling for workers of the world to
unite she wants them to boycott working
another genius idea isn't it you can't
in the middle of a national emergency
even make this stuff up it it's there
for the viewing take a look when we talk
about this idea of reopening society you
know only in America does the president
when the president tweets about
liberation does he mean go back to work
when we you know have this discussion
about going going back or reopening I
think a lot of people should just say no
we're not going back to that we're not
going back to working 70 hour weeks just
so that we could put food on the table
and not even feel any sort of semblance
of security in our lives she's not
working 70 hours
week Nancy Pelosi has everybody home
apparently with a lot of time on their
hands Democratic Party they're
expressing plans to flush capitalism
liberty freedom that would be in our
Constitution as well everything else
that makes this country great right down
the drain and they're not alone knew how
Americans had dying to get back to work
now the United Nations tweeting quote in
the aftermath of the Copa nineteen
pandemic when economic stimulus package
packages composed of infrastructure are
designed as a real opportunity for
long-term systemic shifts with green
packages even fake news CN n why would
they want to be left behind from staying
home to keeping a metered distance from
each other the corona virus pandemic has
drastically changed the way we live why
not do the same for the environment o
airline industries let's kick them in
the teeth while they're down and news
Buster's org they just reported the mob
and the media across multiple outlets
hoping that our lockdown leads to a
major reset and permanent changes for
climate people are still dying we're
trying to save lives
take a look the world is suddenly
learning what can happen if humans stop
polluting the environment something to
think about there many people see this
as a major reset for Humanity in the
planet from wildlife to the environment
that will explore the benefits of those
shelter and place orders across the
country and around the world we do have
some positive news on this Earth Day the
corona virus has been it's just a
terrible crisis a health crisis and
economic crisis and it's just turned
everything upside down but we thought
you'd want to know about some surprising
ways that it's actually helping our
planet this is a great moment a moment
of pause for all of us to realize that
our choices do impact the environment
around us how do I say this nicely in
this profession and it is a profession
we have some really dumb people well
anyway that would surely destroy our way
of life that would have put many
Americans out of work we're trying to
get the country up and running again
every step of the way many on the Left
mob media trying to use coronavirus as
what is a cold calculated political
weapon to
advance their radical agenda over the
past several months they have used it of
course the plunge and president Trump of
course he's a racist a xenophobe of fear
mongerer even accused him pretty much of
killing Americans Pelosi using the
emergency government relief packages as
a personal piggy bank for her favorite
liberal causes withholding money for
hospitals and workers in small business
and large business why so she can get a
hundred and fifty million dollars to the
National Endowment for the Arts and
Humanities 25 million for the Kennedy
Performing Arts Center 75 million for
PBS and national propaganda radio and
she attempted to change election and
immigration laws on top of it
remember workers were waiting they
needed to help save with hospitals and
for the past week she's been held up she
held up funding for small business
paycheck protection the PPP plan to gain
some kind of political leverage yet
again ultimately she caved and funded
the program and a radical Democratic
colleagues and not happy Nancy she took
five minutes away from meeting her
designer I scream take a look we don't
know what's in the package yet we only
know it's been reported but I think what
you're hearing from all of us on the
call is that we have real concerns about
giving away leverage now without getting
some of the priorities that we need
small businesses in this country they
are desperate they there many are taking
pay cuts they are trying to keep their
employees employed and that
congresswoman is only concerned about
giving up political leverage sick ugly
twisted radical repulsive
that's your new modern extreme
Democratic Socialist Party and mob in
the media they're looking out well
they're not looking out for you their
extreme socialist agenda they're green
New Deal apparently more important
Pelosi needs to get on a big carbon
footprint private jet she can bring her
designer ice cream and her big expensive
freezer with her she doesn't want to
bring it I'll mail it to her I'll find a
way get back to Washington she needs to
get back to work passing coronavirus
legislation the business of the country
because everybody else is working the
farmers are farming the Packers
packing the truck drivers delivering the
guys in New York Long Island they are
stocking the shelves our medicines are
here the the health care equipment is
being made and sent also